16 years after the series debut and nine
years after the last numbered entry
saintero is back and looking to reinvent
itself even though the announcement of
the game's new city and drastically
different cast of characters left fans
divided the experience is still looking
to be as wild as previous entries just
don't expect super powers this time
around here's everything we know about
saints row so far
the saints row series is starting from
scratch and so are you as the
protagonist instead of joining a gang
that has already been established you'll
be making a name for yourself and
building up to what will become the
legendary saints however don't think of
this as a prequel to the original game
with this opportunity to start over
series developer volition wanted to
create criminals that were more
relatable and one way of doing that was
to show those goons starting from
nothing the team also thought it was
crucial to introduce new characters due
to major changes in saints row 4 which i
won't spoil here but if you know you
know so who are the new soon to be
saints let's start with the business
mastermind eli who cares more about
making money than how the money is made
next is the getaway driver nina who
basically sounds like the just one more
job and i'm done type because of her
family history with gangs and how she
wants to leave that lifestyle behind and
then there's the gang's people pleaser
kevin who's actually a part of another
gang the idols when you meet him in the
game and finally the leader aka your
character aka the boss ultimately you'll
get to decide who the boss is and what
they do but according to volition the
boss can be described as an
overconfident person that doesn't like
to follow orders each of the new
criminals are just trying to make ends
meet and head out on their own because
they're tired of working for other gangs
their goal is to get rich and take over
the fictional city of santo aliso a huge
and vibrant sandbox in the american
southwest santo aliso will feature a
whole new set of radio stations as well
as familiar and new stores to customize
your boss to your heart's content
like previous games in the series saints
row's gameplay loop revolves around
seizing territory from rival gangs those
gangs include the muscle vehicle and
exercise obsessed los panteros the
anarchist nightclub owners known as the
idols and the private military
corporation martial defense industries
in order to expand your criminal empire
you'll be engaging in a bunch of
different activities including main
quests side quests as well as a new
activity called criminal ventures this
new type of activity will have you doing
things like taking over businesses
across the city to use as a front for
illegal activities gunplay and traversal
are what we've come to expect from the
series however now you'll have more
options when it comes to vehicle combat
from side swiping your enemies to
hopping on top of your car and firing
back as you surf on it there are
multiple ways to take down your foes
while moving there is also the addition
of a wingsuit so players can fly around
the city for fun or eject themselves
from a car open the wingsuit and escape
the scene in style and speaking of style
volition claims to have created the
biggest customization suite of any
saints row game so far and based on one
of the latest trailers i'd say they were
definitely telling the truth with the
new game's in-depth character creator
you'll be able to change nearly
everything about your boss of course
there are tons of clothing options as
well as the return of layered clothing
but in saints row you'll also be able to
customize your skin down to the details
like texture glossiness color veins
scars tans body hair etc you can also
change the features of your entire face
and make it asymmetrical a new addition
to the series and the deep customization
doesn't stop at your character's body
there are also a lot of ways to
personalize the game's vehicles and
weapons as well but will we be able to
have the voice of nolan north i guess
we'll have to wait and see
like previous games in the series saints
row will feature drop in and drop out
cooperative online multiplayer allowing
for you and one other friend to team up
and play together completing missions
while in co-op will transfer over to
your own save so you won't waste time or
lose your boss character's progression
while playing in someone else's game so
if you've just started and you play a
late game mission with a buddy the game
will remember that and not force you to
play that mission over again once you
reach it in your own save
volition plans on releasing three
post-launch expansions for saints row
all of which will be included in the
game's expansion pass they haven't
revealed details about the packs just
yet but we're sure they'll be filled
with mayhem make sure to subscribe to
gamespot so you can get the details when
they're announced
similar to the rest of the series saints
row is being developed by volition and
published by deep silver in an interview
chief creative officer jim boone
mentioned the team at volition used a
handful of action films as reference
points for the reboot films like baby
driver for its vehicular movement hobbs
and shaw for its extravagance and john
wick for its stylized combat jim also
added that today's social climate has
outgrown the tone of prior saints games
aka moving away from sex toys as a
weapon was a bit of a needed change when
it comes to the game's voice talents the
team has only revealed bryce charles the
voice actor for the default boss
saints row will be releasing for both
current and past generation consoles as
well as pc so you'll be able to pick it
up on xbox series x and s xbox one ps4
and 5 and pc via the epic game store
saints row is scheduled to launch on
august 23rd 2022 the game was originally
set to release on february 25th before
being delayed so that the team could do
a little more fine-tuning and honestly
moving it out of february probably paid
off for them as the world was engrossed
with a little game called elden ring
saints row is available for pre-order
both through the game's website and
select online retailers there are three
physical additions to the game standard
which is sixty dollars criminal customs
also sixty dollars and notorious for
ninety dollars there are also three
digital versions of the game standard 60
gold for 90 and platinum for 100 all six
editions have the idols and archie pack
as a pre-order bonus but you'll also get
the saints criminal custom pack for
pre-ordering the criminal customs
notorious gold or platinum editions the
physical criminal customs edition adds
the saints criminal customs pack so it's
basically just an edition designed to
give you an extra bonus for pre-ordering
the game since it costs the same as the
standard edition you might as well grab
the criminal customs edition if you're
planning on pre-ordering the game anyway
finally the notorious edition adds the
expansion pass and comes with physical
collectibles including a steelbook case
like the physical version the digital
version of the standard edition only
includes the base game the gold edition
adds the los panteros american muscle
bundle and the expansion pass the
platinum edition includes all that plus
a digital copy of saints row the third
remastered
so let's recap the new saints row
features new characters a new city
deeper customization new vehicle combat
a wingsuit and loads of ways to cause
mayhem as you rise to the top of the
criminal food chain and there you have
it all of the information that's
currently available for saints row we've
still got a ways to go before august
23rd so expect more details to drop in
the lead up to release make sure you
subscribe to gamespot so you don't miss
out on any of the new updates as well as
our review when it's time you can find
me on social media at devonta chisholm
thanks for watching
you